monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues le bilan de la délinquance en
2019 est mauvais tous les indicateurs
publiés discrètement par le ministre
d'intérieur sont au rouge
il est loin le temps où le ministre
l'intérieur présenté les résultats de
son action devant la presse à la lecture
des chiffres on comprend cette humilité
nouvelles comme en 2018
les coups et blessures volontaires
enregistré une forte hausse
les violences sexuelles explose après
une année 2008 catastrophique
l'augmentation est encore très forte
cette année + 12 % le nombre d'homicides
aura crû de 8 5 % les vols sans violence
de 3% et les escroqueries dont 11%
la police de sécurité du quotidien n'a
pas inversé la tendance dans mon
département dans le quartier de planoise
à besançon le ministre l'intérieur était
venu installer la police de plus
sécurité du quotidien il ya deux ans
nous allons voir ce que nous allons voir
le gouvernement avait trouvé la
situation la solution nous disait ton ce
que nous avons vu avec un commissariat
ouvert à 10h et fermer à 17h ce sont des
tirs de balles journalier huit blessés à
ce jour une fourrière à 100 des plus de
160 véhicules une grande surface hors
d'état la réponse pénale est si faible
qu'elle assume une forme d'impunité
désespérant trop souvent les forces de
police pensez vous monsieur le premier
ministre que la politique annoncée
assumé par la garde des sceaux qui
consiste à réduire le recours à la
castration sur une réponse adéquate
jusqu'où votre politique monsieur le
premier ministre en matière de sécurité
va-t-elle nous emmener